welcome to the Toyota green room we are
talking your heart health with dr. taryn
Rula welcome yes my favorite topic
it's your favorite topic and why are we
not as knowledgeable as we should be in
terms of our bodies and how our heart is
impacted by the everyday stresses that
we deal with I mean why don't we know
this is the number one killer of women I
know and despite the fact that we've
been educating women since 2004 with the
Go Red For Women campaign we still have
this big gap and awareness women just
don't think about heart disease and
stroke as a threat to them they think
about cancer a lot of times but when you
look at the statistics about one out of
three women will die of heart disease
one out of thirty will die of breast
cancer more women die of cardiovascular
disease than all forms of cancer
combined so it really is a big problem
that more women don't appreciate that
but in addition they don't really know
the symptoms or how to recognize them
they don't understand risk factors and
how to manage them so we have a lot more
education we need to do oh we doing
better though we're doing better no
doubt and I think a lot of these
educational and awareness campaigns have
accomplished a lot in terms of saving
women and making them healthier but we
still have much more to do so that's why
the days like this where we wear red and
raise awareness and tell our stories
it's really important so what should
women what are the signs right so a lot
of times unfortunately with heart
disease it can be silent and that's one
of the things that makes it so deadly so
you can feel well and you can have high
blood pressure or high cholesterol or
diabetes or plaque in the arteries that
supply blood to your heart and you don't
know you have it until the day you have
your first heart attack or stroke so
that makes it difficult and I think
that's one of the problems with
cardiovascular disease but if you do
have symptoms by far and away chest pain
most common symptom for women but it
doesn't have to be the kind where you
flex your chest and fall over on the
floor and it's horrible it's subtle it
can be subtle it can be kind of up here
in the chest it can be more down here
like indigestion right so some people
say I have indigestion and that's all it
is and they don't really get it checked
out but then women can also get things
like shortness of breath fatigue
lightheadedness feeling kind of sweaty
or clammy arm pain jaw pain or back
so some of these other symptoms that may
not make them think I should have my
heart checked out those are also
symptoms or what we associate with
anxiety it can be and I mean I had I
can't tell you how many women have come
into my office and said that they've
seen other doctors and their doctor told
them that they're just anxious or
stressed yesterday I had a woman in my
office and she said I can't walk more
than three blocks before getting short
of breath and I'm coming to see you
because the last person I saw told me
I'm depressed and I need to see a
psychiatrist so unfortunately in the
medical community we have not always
taken women's complaint seriously and
that has contributed to the problem at
what age should we start seriously
taking a look at our vitals early
earlier than I think a lot of people
think about so the recommendation by the
American Heart Association for example
is to start having your blood pressure
and your cholesterol checked as early as
age 20 so a lot of people in their 20s
and 30s are not thinking about this and
one thing I think that women can really
do that would be helpful is what happens
to women during pregnancy can be a
marker of their future risk really yes
and so we know women go every year to
get their pap smear they get care you
know in with their OB guide and that's a
great time to think about what might be
happening with my cardiovascular system
so if they have preeclampsia or
gestational diabetes or gestational high
blood pressure or even babies that are
low birth weight all of these things can
signal that they might be at increased
risk down the line so the the ob/gyns
office is actually a good place for
women to start the conversation is that
because of the stress of the baby it's
like a stress test exactly exactly so I
want to know for for someone who has
notoriously low blood pressure that's
good cholesterol in check and all of a
sudden you go to the doctor and you see
all of a sudden a spike in your blood
pressure a spike in your cholesterol
measuring and you've hit that certain
age is that the time when you need to be
concerned and say okay this is where I
really need the rubber meets the road
yeah I mean cardiovascular disease is
all about prevention prevention
prevention because it takes time in some
cases for the problem to occur so for
plaque to buildup in the arteries it
doesn't happen overnight it's over years
and so
all the things that you're doing ahead
of time to kind of prepare and plan and
keep your numbers down and in the right
range are really important to prevent
that first event like a heart attack or
stroke remember happening so certainly
we know that risk for women goes up over
the age of 55 or when they're
postmenopausal that's kind of the age
cutoff and then we think about things
like family history so you may have a
normal blood pressure and great
cholesterol levels but if you have a
very strong family history of early
heart disease that's something that we
need to know as your doctor because it
plays into your risk and if your parents
or grandparents died from the disease
yep so we look at the whole family tree
but in particular we pay attention to
what we call first-degree relatives
meaning your parents or your siblings
and we look to see did a woman a
first-degree relative have an early
heart attack or stroke before the age of
65 did a man have an early heart attack
or stroke before the age of 55 and if
they did that's a marker for high risk
what are the biggest risk factors you
can avoid so high blood pressure
one of the biggest abnormal cholesterol
levels so a high LDL or bad cholesterol
a low HDL or good cholesterol diabetes
diabetes is a big big risk factor and
then smoking so those are kind of the
big ones and then you think about things
like obesity lack of exercise stress too
much alcohol these are kind of the
traditional ones that we look at what's
interesting for women is they have a lot
of these ones that we don't often talk
about that can put them at higher risk
so things like polycystic ovarian
syndrome we talked about pregnancy
issues early menopause migraines with
aura women who have autoimmune disorders
like lupus or rheumatoid arthritis or
even psoriatic arthritis all of these
things can and mental health I didn't
mention but very important depression
anxiety these can all play into
elevating a woman's risk of
cardiovascular disease and why is that
we don't know for a lot of these reasons
the exact pathophysiology or mechanisms
we're learning about it you know in some
cases for example with stress we know
that you have a release of a lot of
these fight-or-flight hormones stress
hormones like cortisol that can increase
inflammation that can increase your
blood pressure and your heart rate so
for some of them we have an idea of the
pathway for others the of the those risk
factors we're still figuring it out
what's the best thing you can do for
yourself the best thing you can do is to
have
a what we used to call it or what we
call a well woman exam where you
basically go to see your doctor you know
you find out your numbers and you talk
about your risk you have your doctor sit
down and say with you Michelle you know
your risk of a heart attack or stroke in
the next 10 years is 2% or it's 20% and
then you figure out a plan what do you
need to do I need to lose weight I need
to exercise whatever it is for you and
sometimes it includes medication things
like aspirin or cholesterol-lowering
medications or drugs to treat
hypertension so but really I think it's
just putting the idea in your head that
this is something I need to pay
attention to even if I feel well even if
my numbers are good I should have this
on my radar at the top of my list of
things that should be a priority because
there's no quick fix there's no quick
fix and unfortunately women tend to
prioritize themselves last last on the
list you know husband kids work
everything else is first and they really
many times ignore a lot of the symptoms
they're having for a while and that can
be problematic because for example you
know we know that this damage can happen
over time for a lot of these diseases
and then once you have a heart attack
those cells start to die they don't come
back
they don't regenerate and so you form
scar tissue that can put you at risk for
heart failure so always better to catch
things early errs to start to treat them
earlier prevention is key it is glass of
wine in there - I actually think we do
say that as a woman you're allowed one
drink a day really you are and so I
actually tend to tell my patients if
they're going to choose a drink red wine
is a good choice because it has
flavonoids in it which is the same
compound in dark chocolate that kind of
tends to help blood vessel health dark
chocolate good - our chocolate and wine
can go tonight and that is your heart
healthy dr. taryn Rula thank you so much
Michelle